The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So today's lecture,
in some sense
is actually out of sequence
by one from Thursday,
but based on when
I was able to get
Dan Frey to be able to come
in and give his lecture.
This is a lecture today on
variance estimation, which
is kind of a topic that probably
ought to come after Thursday's,
because Thursday's is
still in the area of design
of experiments, response surface
modeling, and optimization.
So it's kind of a nice wrap-up
to the last three or four
lectures that we've been doing.
So we'll come back
to that on Thursday.
But what I want to
do today is this idea
of nested variance components.
And the readings
for this material
are not in either
of the textbooks.
There's a separate
chapter that is
on the website under Readings.
And it's chapter
3 from this book
by David Drain, Statistical
Methods for Industrial Process
Control.
I think he's still
there, I'm not sure.
He's a statistician for Intel.
And actually, although the
title doesn't indicate it,
it's all about
semiconductor manufacturing
and statistical
methods for that.
But this idea of variance
components is actually,
it does come up, and
I've never actually
seen it covered in any of the
standard statistics texts.
So I think it's a very
powerful and important idea,
and that's why I wanted
to talk about it today.
In addition to this book as
a reading on the website,
we also have spreadsheets.
There's a spreadsheet with
three different worksheets in it
that are the two main examples
out of the Drain book.
He just pulls up
the data, and then
uses some statistics
package to pull out
things like the ANOVA table.
I actually show
you the spreadsheet
with all the
intermediate calculations
for both analysis of
variance and this estimation
of variance components in it.
So you'll find that very useful.
You may find it really
useful as a template for some
of the work on the
problem set as well.
OK, so what I want
to do is first
off, refresh ourselves a little
bit on analysis of variance.
So in some sense,
this is actually
a little bit of a
refresher, first on ANOVA,
and then deepening of our
understanding, hopefully,
of ANOVA.
So indirectly, it's a little
bit of review for the quiz.
But then I want to
talk a little bit
about a different assumption
of the model, or the underlying
problem that's being
looked at, that leads away
from standard ANOVA, towards
this idea of nested variance.
And briefly, what
nested invariance is,
is structures in which you
may have more than one source
of random variation at work.
And a classic example in
semiconductor manufacturing
would be this spatial hierarchy
of structures like chips,
you have 50, 100, 1000
chips on each wafer.
And you may have chip-to-chip
variance, for example.
And then you may have a certain
number of wafers in a lot
or a boat of wafers that all are
typically processed together.
So I might have 24
wafers in each lot.
And I may have
wafer-to-wafer variance.
Similarly, I may run multiple
lots over time in one line.
So I have lot-to-lot variation.
And very often, you're
gathering lots and lots
of data, much data.
And you're trying to
say, OK, how much of it
is die-to-die variation?
How much of it is
wafer-to-wafer variation?
How much lot-to-lot?
You want to separate out or
decompose the total variation
that you're seeing into each
of these different components.
The standard ANOVA isn't
really set up to do that.
And that's what I'm going
to talk about today,
is try to show you what
ANOVA assumes, which
is looking for a fixed effect
between different design
points, or different replicates.
And then this notion
of nested structures,
where you have things
within other things
within other things, or
groups within other groups
within other groups.
And so that's the key plan.
So what I want to
do is again, refresh
us a little bit
on standard ANOVA,
then be fairly
explicit about what
the model is that underlies
these nested variance
structures.
And then we'll actually
go back and work
through how we extend
the ideas of ANOVA
to actually be able to estimate
these different variances.
And then finally, there
are some implications
of these variance
structures for how
you would design experiments.
So for example, if you
want to get the best
estimate possible for
that die-to-die variation,
should you make more
die measurements?
Or should you have more
wafer measurements?
How would you allocate
a total budget
of measurements across that
nested variance structure?
So that's the plan.
And the key idea
here, again, is there
is a big difference, an
important difference that I
want to cover between
the standard ANOVA
and these nested
variance structures.
So what is it in standard
ANOVA we were doing?
So there was a very basic
question in the standard ANOVA,
which is, we're basically
asking, if I were just having
a single source of
random variation at work,
and we make, actually,
the assumption that we're
sampling from a normal
distribution, when
I look from one
group to another,
do I see evidence that something
besides just random sampling
from that single normal
distribution is at work?
Is there a fixed effect
that is large enough
that I think it's more than
just a random chance that I got
an observed difference
between the means of a couple
of different groups?
And the basic
approach mechanically
to do that was first off,
we needed some estimate
of the variance of just
the natural variation,
the pure replication error.
And what we basically did is
treated each of our treatment
groups, looked at
each one, and said,
OK, there's a local mean
of that treatment group.
What's the replication variance
around that local mean?
I wasn't changing
now the parameters.
But for each of the ones
with the design fixed,
I just looked at replication.
So that was one estimate,
that's our natural variation.
Second, we looked at the
group-to-group deviations.
And we said, either this
is due to a fixed effect,
a systematic fixed effect that's
different between those two
groups, or it's just random
chance because of sampling.
And then we looked at the
ratio of those two variances,
and said, by random
chance alone, what
would I expect based on the
size of the samples, the number
of data points going
into each of those?
Look at the F ratio for
the statistics associated
with that ratio
of variance to see
if it is likely to have
occurred by chance alone.
All sounds familiar?
You could do that in your sleep?
OK.
So here pictorially
is what was going on
with the ANOVA example.
And in fact, I think this
was the ANOVA example.
I think that we
did the actual data
we used when we first introduced
ANOVA a few weeks ago.
It's the simplest
possible ANOVA setup
you could have with
four data points.
And what's beautiful
about four data
points is we could actually do
the whole calculation by hand.
So here was the situation.
I had two different groups,
group 1, group 2, the data
points 3 and 5, 7 and 9.
And again, the basic
idea is, we need
to estimate number 1, the
within group variation.
And here we have two
different local means
with two different
estimates of variance.
We pool those to get a pooled
estimate of natural variation.
And then we looked
at the between group,
the deviation between the
means of the two groups.
And we used that to estimate
a group-to-group variance.
And then we looked at the
ratio between those two.
And we saw it in this example.
I can't remember, I think
it was fairly marginal
with this few data points,
whether it was actually,
in fact, statistically
significant,
whether this mean effect
was real or not, because so
few data points,
it's really quite
a large spread in the variances
that you might actually come up
with by chance.
OK, so what I want to do is
go back and mathematically
identify what the implied models
were with the standard ANOVA.
This is kind of
pedantic here, because I
think we do understand this.
But I'm going to
extend this in a minute
and contrast it with
the nested variance.
So I want to be
very, very clear.
Our null hypothesis
in ANOVA, what
we think is happening if
there's no fixed effects,
is basically every
data point simply
is being drawn from
the same distribution.
And it has some fixed
mean, and then it's
got some random variation.
And each sample is
being pulled from
the same normal
distribution with just one
underlying variance at work.
And recall that variance
might be measurement variance
together with process variance,
but it's all identical.
So that's what's happening
if there is no fixed effect.
The alternative hypothesis
that we're looking at,
and we're trying to see
is there evidence of,
says basically that there
is a fixed effect going on.
Now I'm going to introduce
a little bit of notation,
and I actually spent
some time trying
to do the best I could
to make this notation
consistent throughout
all of the slides today.
We'll see if I succeeded
in that, because there was
a lot of changes to notation.
I'm going to use
the i subscript here
in this case to indicate
what later we'll
see is the outermost
level of variance.
So in this simple picture,
now as we go through,
i indicates here,
which subgroup I'm in.
So in our simple data,
I had two subgroups.
I had group 1 and group
2 with two data points.
So the i subscript here
could be either 1 or 2,
indicating group 1 or 2.
And so the point is, there may
be a fixed offset, either t1
or t2 from the grand mean,
as a fixed effect associated
with being a member
of that group.
And now the j is a subscript
with this funky little notation
down here, that indicates
this is data point
j, the jth replicate within,
read those parens right there,
within subgroup i.
So I had two replicates
within each subgroup i.
And the simple point here is
that our alternative hypothesis
is, there is this fixed
offset, t1 or t2, at work,
in addition to the
random variation.
And that's what we're trying
to look at the estimate for.
But this is standard ANOVA.
And so there is
still this assumption
that there really is only
one random variation at work.
There's only one random
source of variation,
and then there's this
fixed effect on top
of that that's repeatable.
It's systematic.
Now, what I'm also going to
do, this is a slide I added.
I'm going to show a
simple ANOVA table.
This in fact, we showed
you earlier a few weeks ago
for that very
simple set of data.
And then I'll go back
to the previous slide,
just to be very careful on some
of the subscripts and notation
that I'm using.
But this is essentially
the same data
that I was talking about before.
We have two groups.
And within each group,
we had two replicates.
And this part up here
is the scratch worksheet
that I might use to generate our
ANOVA table down at the bottom.
These are the sorts
of calculations
that either your statistics
package would do,
or you would do by hand.
And it includes things like
calculating the group average
for each of those two groups.
Remember the average
of 3 and 5 is 4,
and the average of 7 and 9 is 8.
And then some additional
squared deviation calculations
that go into ultimately the
sum of squared deviations
calculation that falls
into the sum of squares
column in your table.
After which we divide by the
degrees of freedom to get
these mean square estimates.
So I've got these little
notations, s sub d, s sub g,
s sub e, and then sum of squared
deviations, sum of squared g,
sum of squared e.
And that's what I've
tried to detail out here
what these definitions
are, back here in slide 7.
So this is still intermediate
calculations, standard ANOVA.
This is still all review.
But some of the calculations,
some of the terms
that go into that, with a little
bit of this funky new notation.
So again, recall what we need
to do is look at OK, what is--
sometimes down here.
Our first thing is our
estimate of what just
pure replicate error is.
We're just looking for
pure replicate error.
And that's basically
looking and saying,
I've got my local mean per
group i, group 1 or group 2.
And then I've got
the data within that.
That's just the deviation
of that individual point
from its local mean.
I can take the square
of that deviation.
And then I take the
sum of that over all
of my data, sum of squared
deviations, as my ss sub e.
That's my sum of squared
deviations in all
of my data from the local mean.
That's not quite my
estimate of variance.
If I now take sse and divide
it by the degrees of freedom,
that gives me my
mean square error,
which is my estimate of
the underlying variance.
Right?
Now the other things
that we do, we
said the second piece here is we
also look at the fixed effect.
So here, we're just looking
at the deviations of the group
mean from the grand mean.
And so here's the local mean,
and here's the grand mean.
That has the double bar
over it, if you can quite
see the notation there.
And so for that, I've also
got a sum of squared errors
here in ssg.
This is the total sum of
squared deviations, one
for each data point.
So each data point shares
the same group mean.
So I'll have multiple
entries in the table.
Because if I have multiple
replicates, they all share
the same group mean.
But I'm basically
saying, OK, all of those
contribute to group
mean deviations
in the total
deviations in my data.
And then the last thing, I'm
going to put a 0 by this.
Because this last thing is
sort of the total deviations
in your data from
the grand mean.
This is just your raw sum
of squared deviations.
So I just calculate
my grand mean,
and I treat all of
my data equally,
whether it's within
a group or not.
And that's just throwing all
of my data into one big bucket,
calculating a grand
mean, and saying,
there's a total, total amount
of sum of squared deviations
in that data.
And what we want to
do is actually take
that total amount of
deviations, and now divvy it up,
and say, how much of it is going
to be because of group to group
variation, and how much of
it is pure replication data?
That's where we're
going to want to get to.
But in standard ANOVA,
what we simply do
is remember that ssd is
equal to the sum of the ssg
and the sum of the sse.
It was in fact, sort
of a crude attempt
at divvying up the total
squared deviations.
But what we'll see is that
it's actually not the right way
to get an estimate of
the underlying variances.
And so now in this table,
that's all that was going on.
I just applied all
of these formulas
to get the scratchpad
to work, and then
put that into the ANOVA table.
And in this case, we saw the
total sum of squared deviations
from the grand mean.
We have an estimate
there of the mean square.
We had the group to
group sum of square
and the replicate
sum of squares.
We could use that
to form an f test.
And we see that it's
only 89% confidence
that in fact you would observe
that big of a ratio by chance
alone.
So if I had a cutoff of 95%
confidence or 90% confidence
with that data, I
would have said,
sorry, I don't have
strong enough evidence
to say that there's
actually a group effect.
There's not a fixed
effect here in this data.
OK?
So what's wrong with that?
That's all great.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But if what you're
really trying to do
is deal with a different
situation, a nested variance
situation, that simple ANOVA
can actually lead you astray.
So now, we're actually
shifting to a different model.
But it's a model that I
think comes up quite a bit,
which is, instead of saying
there was a fixed effect,
so every time I had group 1, I
would have a deviation t sub 1
for that group.
What if every time instead,
I had pulled another sample
that I just lumped
together as group 1?
Maybe it's a new wafer.
It in fact, has a
wafer random variation,
coming from a different
source than the replicate data
within that wafer.
So in other words,
I'm moving away
from a fixed effect
group to group,
to a random effect
group to group.
There's a different
random model,
a g sub i here, which
is not the fixed effect.
I guess we called that a t
sub i in the previous model.
But in fact, this g
sub i is now also drawn
from a different
random variation,
or a different normal
distribution, in this case.
I have a very different model.
Now, what I'm really interested
in is dealing with a situation
where there's two different
variances at work.
I still have replication
variance, or the within
group variance.
So imagine again, I'm pulling
now two different wafers.
g1 is now wafer 1,
g2 is now wafer 2.
And within that, I measure
two different chips.
Now what I'm
interested in knowing
is what the chip-to-chip
variance is,
and what the
wafer-to-wafer variance
is, as if it were random.
So that's the key difference.
And what we want to do is
still be able to decide,
is there something
significant going on?
But really, what I
want to do is estimate
what those variances are.
So here's the same picture.
This is the same data.
But now, I have a
different kind of picture.
I still need to estimate
number one, which
is the within group variances.
But now instead of having a
fixed effect, what I want to
do--
let me call that 2 star.
I want to attribute the
group-to-group deviations
that I observe as
indications of or samples
of group-to-group variances.
So is this setup clear?
OK.
So our real goal here is to
estimate these two variances.
And by the way, point
estimates are not
going to be good enough.
We actually want confidence
intervals on these estimates.
So that's going to get
a little bit tricky.
But what we would
like to actually do
is decompose the total
variance we observe,
estimate what the
total variance is,
and decompose it into these
two different sources.
So, here's our first attempt.
I'll call this
the naive attempt.
Why don't we just reuse
all those calculations
we already had for ANOVA?
Aren't they really
telling us the same thing?
Think of it.
Back in ANOVA, we were
already saying, OK,
under the null hypothesis,
we had replication variance,
and we had a variance due
to group-to-group variation.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
DUANE BONING: Can't
I just use those
directly as my estimates
of the two variances?
I had a ratio of those two.
Why aren't those two
just great estimates
of those two variances?
So our naive attempt,
our first attempt,
is let's just use
what we already did.
Number one, we had an estimate
of pure replication error.
Think of that as within
group variance, right?
Let's just reuse that.
That's our estimate of
within group variance.
Number two, we had this
between group thing.
We had a group mean square,
deviation of the group means.
Why not simply estimate
the group-to-group variance
as the mean square of
that group deviations?
So some squared group-to-group
deviations divided
by the degrees of freedom.
And in terms of total
variance, if I assume,
again, there are two
different variances at work,
there is within group
and group-to-group,
and they're independent, then
my total variance should just
be the sum of those.
Why don't I simply use that sum
of squared deviation divided
by the degrees of freedom?
It's just a total mean
squared deviation.
Why not use that as my estimate,
just my total variance?
Throw all my data
into one big bucket,
calculate total variance.
Isn't that my best estimate
of the total variance
in the system?
Seems natural, doesn't it?
In fact, we can
calculate the grand mean,
I can calculate
the grand variance.
Isn't that a great
estimate of total variance
in the system under this model?
And well, the good news is, at
least something still sticks.
The within group variance
estimate is still good.
But we would be wrong,
and I'll show you
why, in this naive
approach, with our estimate
of between group variance.
And bizarrely, we're even
wrong on our estimate
of total variance in the system,
just using all of our data,
undifferentiated.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are they
supposed to be
[INAUDIBLE] really the sum
of the other two [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: So the question
here, for folks in Singapore,
was, shouldn't the last
one be equal to the sum
of this one, a plus b?
Shouldn't that equal the total?
And the answer is no.
If you actually look back at
the ANOVA table, let me do that.
If you look back
at the ANOVA table,
let's look at it down
here at the bottom.
The sum of squares is the
one that is conserved.
So your total
squared deviations,
you break apart into within
group or group-to-group.
But by the time you divide
it by degrees of freedom,
the mean square or the
variances do not add.
And that's weird.
And it turns out, in our second
problem, the nested variance
structure, they should add.
We're saying, there is
two different sources
of variance at work.
There's within group
invariance, there's
group-to-group variance,
they're independent.
So my total variance actually
should be the sum of the two.
And we're going to use
that knowledge, actually,
to help us with
estimating things.
So in fact, your insight is
right, not for standard ANOVA,
but it is right for the
nested variance structure.
Now that I've broken down your
confidence in using ANOVA,
hopefully, and we
can rebuild what
it is we really want to do.
I think we've already talked
about this a little bit.
Again, I think that these nested
variance structures actually
arise a lot in any
kind of process
where there's any kind
of batch processing
at work, either in
time or in space.
So it's easiest, in my
mind, maybe because I'm just
mostly familiar with
semiconductor manufacturing,
to really see that.
But I think it's much more
generally true anytime
I have some grouping of stuff,
of parts, material, whatever,
that I want to look at stuff
within that group, and then
group-to-group, and
maybe then there's
a hierarchy where there's
a larger group of groups.
And I want to estimate
variances within that.
That kind of hierarchical
or nested structure, I think
comes up all the time.
And an important point that I
haven't really explicitly said,
but would like to
mention here, is
that the reason we're interested
in estimating these variances
differently, is that
very often, physically
in the process, the source of
the variation at each of those
levels is actually different.
It's a different
orthogonal, different kind
of variation source.
So for example,
in the wafer case,
the source of
variation chip-to-chip
may have to do with
non-uniformity within the tool,
maybe spatial or other kinds
of random, in many cases
even spatial
systematic variations.
But the point is, there's
a different kind of set
of physics governing
how well-matched each
of those chips are
within one wafer.
It's a different
source of physics
than every new wafer I put
into that single wafer tool,
from one time to the next.
That may also have deviations
due to how well I can control
some of the parameters
of that process in time
from one run to the next.
So it seems very
natural that indeed,
the variance, the underlying
variation in those two cases,
are different.
They are orthogonal.
They are in some sense,
additive in that sense.
They are uncorrelated.
And we'll use that assumption.
But there's that underlying
assumption in here.
If, in fact, it's just
arbitrary grouping where there's
only one source of
variation at work,
and it's just random
pulling of things to form,
in fact, different
groups, then that's
more like the standard ANOVA.
But when there's a nested
structure, items within items
within other items,
usually there's
a different source of
physics that were causing
the variation at each level.
OK, so again, our
goal is to estimate
each of these sources of
variation, both point estimates
and confidence intervals.
Here's some examples.
I think we've already
talked about this.
The within wafer versus
say, the wafer-to-wafer,
or run-to-run variability.
OK, so let me build
up a little bit
of the explicit
model for this case,
especially with multiple
layers of nesting.
We'll start without nesting.
Then we'll do one
level of nesting.
And then working up
to the second example,
we'll do a three-level,
two levels of nesting.
But we basically
will have points
within wafers within lots.
So in fact, you can
keep extending that.
You could have lots within
products, and products
within fabs, and who knows?
You could get further detailed.
But here's the simplest model.
And this really is
the pure variance case
without any nesting at all.
We basically have our
individual measurements,
there's an overall mean.
And then there's some
random variation occurring.
And here I'm indicating
that I'm taking
multiple measurements, multiple
samples, multiple replicates
with this m sub i.
And the point is, it's simply
a 0 mean normal distribution
with some variance.
And as we've said, many of
our assumptions still hold.
And in fact, we often make
these assumptions and use them,
and we have to be
careful in some
of the spatial situations
I've talked about,
because they don't
actually hold.
In some sense, what we're
assuming in this case is,
I'm taking multiple
measurements on the same wafer.
But I'm assuming randomness
in those measurements.
I'm assuming each of those
individual measurements,
or each of those
individual replicates
is IIND, identically and
independently distributed
from a normal distribution.
That's 0 mean with all
sharing the same variance.
And just as a precursor,
we'll come back to this,
actually, in one of
the case studies.
If I have within
wafer variation,
chip-to-chip variation, and
I have a systematic variance,
center to edge,
maybe it's always
thinner in the middle
of the wafer and thicker
on the edge of the wafer,
that's a systematic effect
that this model is not
really good at capturing.
So you've got to be careful.
This is actually a
fairly strong assumption
of random sampling within
that particular scenario.
OK, but this is the simple case.
Now let's look at this
variance structure.
And here I'm using exactly the
notation out of Drain's book.
So when you read
Drain's chapter,
this should look
familiar to you.
In this case, now I've
got an overall mean.
And again, we've
got a wafer effect.
It's not a fixed effect,
it's a random effect.
Meaning every time I pull a
new wafer out of my samples,
all of the data points on it
will share the same offset.
It's an offset of w sub i.
But w sub i itself, or
wafer sub 1, or wafer sub 2,
is itself drawn from a 0
mean normal distribution
with variance sigma
squared sub w.
So the amount of wafer offset
for that particular wafer
is randomly sampled.
And then within that, I
make multiple measurements,
I make j measurements
within wafer sub i.
And each of those
individual measurements
is itself also
randomly distributed.
OK?
So that's just repeating
what our situation here was.
But now, instead of
using that generic model,
I'm really trying to illustrate
it with wafers and measurements
within wafers.
So if I take this basic
formula right here,
and I basically
ask, OK, now if I
want to do variance
calculations,
if I do a variance
on this, what is
the variance I'm going to
observe in my total data?
Probably should have replicated
that equation right up here.
We had xij is equal to mu
plus w sub i plus m j of i.
So if I threw all of my data
into one big bucket, xij,
and I simply calculated the
variance across all of my data,
what should not just
my data, but in fact,
if I had the total
population, infinite
numbers of measurement, what
would the variance of that be?
And we're saying that the w
sub i and the measurements
within that are independent.
So that these
variances add, there's
no correlation between them.
The variance of a constant is 0.
We have the
wafer-to-wafer variance,
so that's my sigma square w.
And I have my
measurement variance.
And so my total variance,
my total true variance,
is simply the sum of those two
other independent variances.
And so that's your
earlier intuition
that Nalish was talking about.
So the individual variances
are assumed to be independent.
And again, that was not
true in that naive attempt.
So how do we do it?
How do I use the data to
actually get good estimates
of these independent variances?
And here's the key idea.
We've got sampling at work.
Essentially within
the replicates,
I've got additional
variances going on, because
of measurement or
replication variance.
And that is contaminating
or adding some noise
to my estimate of the
group-to-group variance.
So what we basically need
to do is unwrap that,
recognize that I've got
multiple samples around that,
and pull out that
random variance away
from our best estimate of
the group-to-group variance.
We need to account for the
fact that I've got also
sampling noise going on
when I'm trying to estimate
the group-to-group variance.
So what happens
is, if I calculate
the wafer average observed
variance just from my data,
So if I observe w bar, I
observe wafer average 1, wafer
average 2, wafer
average 3, and I look
at the variances of these,
the observed variance
in the wafer
averages actually has
the true wafer-to-wafer
variance in it.
But it's also got this
sampling noise attached to it.
And so what we want
to do is, to get
to the true variance of just
the wafer-to-wafer variance,
I need to subtract this
off of the observed.
So if this, now again, is
my observed wafer-to-wafer
average variance, I subtract
off the sampling noise, my best
estimate because of sampling.
And that gives me
my best estimate
of the actual
wafer-to-wafer variance.
Now, I added a slide
here that actually
shows a derivation of this.
But I hope, before I
go into the derivation,
hopefully there's
good intuition here.
This is just the sampling
contamination of noise, right?
And for example, if I had a
million replicate measurements,
so if m were a million,
I would be averaging out
all of those small measurements,
pure replication deviations.
There are 0 mean.
So on average, this term
gets smaller and smaller
with more and more
sampling of the wafer.
And what I would
observe in that case,
from my wafer-to-wafer
average variance,
is really, really
close to the true one.
This is only a problem
when m is small.
And I've got lots of
replicate noise or measurement
noise contaminating
my estimate of
the wafer-to-wafer variation.
So hopefully there's some
degree of intuition here
that makes sense.
If I actually now go in
and do the calculation,
first off, what I said is we
have three or four or five
different wafers, and I have
some number of measurements
within each wafer.
And I'm simply calculating
for each of those wafers what
the observed average is.
Up here is the formula
for the wafer average.
And then down here, I'm just
applying various mathematics
to that formula.
And so what's going on
here is, we can see,
we've got our wafer
average for wafer sub i,
is simply 1 over the
measurements for all of the j
replicates, 1 through m.
We've got m replicates of
that within that wafer sub i.
Which I've just
expanded out, I just
plugged in x sub i in here.
Now if I expand
that summation out,
I've got m replicates of mu.
So that's my m mu.
I've got m replicates,
all with the same w sub i.
So that's that right there.
And then I've got
my remaining part
of my sum for my
individual replicates.
And just multiplying that
out, my overall wafer average
for that wafer sub i is mu
plus the shared offset because
of the sample for
that particular wafer,
and then all my
measurement noise.
And now I can apply my
variance to the observed,
this is the observed
wafer-to-wafer average,
is the variance of the
mean, which again, is 0,
because that's just a constant.
This is the true
variance, sigma w squared.
And then here, I've
got m replicates,
all with the same variance.
So I've got a constant,
which gives me,
when I do my variance math,
my 1 constant squared, my 1
over m squared.
And then the sum gives
me m equal variances.
So that's where we get back
to our basically 1 over m
sampling variance.
So that's the derivation
going on, if you actually
want to see the whole detail.
But again, all that
that's trying to say
is, if I actually look,
group-to-group in the observed
means, it's got two
things inside of it.
It's got the true
wafer variance.
But it's also got noise.
And the noise comes from
the underlying measurement
noise or the underlying
replicate noise,
reduced by the factor of
number of replicates I have.
My typical 1 over n
reduction in variance.
But that's what's
contaminating my noise.
So once I have that, there's one
quick observation to make here.
Before we actually
use that to get back
to our estimate of what the
true variance is, is to go back
to the earlier point we made.
We said that the total variance,
the true total variance
should be the independent
sum of these two
sources of other variance.
But the same sampling
contamination also
occurs not just for what
our observed wafer-to-wafer
variance is, but if I
were, in fact, to actually
calculate my grand variance in
just the data that I observed,
I took all of my data,
threw it into one pool,
calculated a mean, and then did
the sum of squared deviations
of all of my data from
the grand mean, divided it
by the number of data
points I had minus 1,
I used one degree of freedom
to calculate the grand mean.
So I'm just estimating the total
variance in all of my data.
That's the sigma
squared t observed.
The observed total
variance is different,
is not equal to the actual true,
total variance in my system
at work.
In fact, the observed
variance will always
be smaller than the
actual observed variance.
And the reason is, if I look
at the total observed variance,
oops.
I think this is an error here.
I think this should be a d.
That should be ss sub d.
My total sum of
squared deviations
divided by m minus 1.
I've also expanded it out into
where that data is coming from.
And the point is, I've
got my wafer variances,
I've got my
measurement variances,
and I've got some number of
replications of each of those.
And if I expand that out,
essentially what I've got
is multiple samples at work.
When I make my observed
calculation of total variance,
that are factors
that are multiplying
times the true underlying
independent sources
of variance, but with factors
that are always smaller than 1.
In other words, I've got m
kinds of replications going on
with sampling from multiple
samples from replication.
And I always get that 1 over
and reduction in variance.
I've got that same
thing happening,
both within the
measurement reduction,
and within the wafer reduction.
So the simple
point here is, this
is why that naive attempt
to just use total variance
and use that as my estimate
of the true independent sum
of variances at work,
why that doesn't apply,
why that doesn't work.
So, now we've got
a strategy here.
What we're going to do
is number one, estimate
within group variances.
That's still OK.
Number two, we're going
to see the observed
group-to-group variance, but
then account for sampling,
subtract off the sigma
squared m over m, from that,
to get our best estimate of
true group-to-group variance.
Now I have
group-to-group variance,
I have within group
variance, I can
add those to get my best
estimate of total variance.
That's the strategy.
So let's go back to our really
simple nested variance example,
and use that strategy
not the naive approach,
but replacing the
naive approach and see
how the numbers come out.
So again, here this was
step one of our strategy.
But within group variance,
that's still the same.
The observed
group-to-group variance
is simply this
mean, which was 4,
and this mean, which was 8 from
the grand mean, which was 6.
So each of those
group-to-group deviations is 2.
And that's squared,
I've got 4 plus 4 is 8.
So that's my observed
group-to-group variance.
And that's actually
the same number
that we had calculated
using regular ANOVA.
And then we did the
ratio between those two
in order to decide if there was
something significant going on.
But now the point is, that
was our contaminated estimate
of group-to-group.
That's our observed.
It may be hard to see there,
that's the g to g bar.
That's our group-to-group
observed averages.
And so now we want to account
for the contamination,
subtract off the
sampling effect to get
to our best estimate of the
true group-to-group variance.
And it's what we
observed, the 8.
But now, using sampling to
subtract the true variance.
So this is our sigma
squared m divided
by the number of measurements
I had in each of those groups,
the sampling effect, which
was m equals 2, in this case.
So I'm subtracting
that component off.
So I'm peeling that part out.
And I get a best estimate now
of the true group-to-group
variance is 7.
So now I've got, within group
is 2, group-to-group is 7.
My total is now the
sum of those two, or 9.
So that's different than
what we had seen before.
Our observed total variance,
I can't remember what it was.
But it was smaller than that.
OK, that's pretty much
the core of the idea.
Let's just do a
couple of examples.
And these are examples
out of Drain's book.
This is the one
starting on page 196.
So it's a little bit more data
than our four data points.
But the basic idea
is still there.
And this example is looking
at the resistivity variation
across multiple wafers.
So he has 6 different
wafers, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and 6.
And in each case, he's making
three replicate measurements.
So we have to be careful again.
We're assuming
that he's randomly
sampling within the wafer to get
replicate measurements of the
within wafer variation.
And then we're looking
at wafer-to-wafer.
Qualitatively, before we
start going and applying
all this machinery, what is
this data basically telling you,
qualitatively?
And then we'll see if, in
fact, the calculations come out
with something that
looks consistent to that.
First off, do you
think the within wafer
variation is bigger, or is
the wafer-to-wafer variation
bigger?
There's a total amount of
deviation in this data.
But where's the
main source of this?
Percentage-wise, what do you
think the lion's share is?
AUDIENCE: You have the
wafer-to-wafer variance.
DUANE BONING: Yeah,
it's pretty clear.
There's nice clustering
within each wafer.
There is some spread, we
have to think about that.
But it looks like
there's perhaps bigger
wafer-to-wafer
deviations than there
are within wafer deviations.
So I'd kind of be looking to
see if I'm decomposing these two
sources of variance.
I am expecting the
wafer-to-wafer variance
to be a little bit larger.
But I'm not completely
sure, because they're
spread within both.
So I'd like to do
the right thing
and get good estimates
of these two things.
So Drain then goes
through, and does an ANOVA.
By the way, you can still
do the typical ANOVA,
because in fact, a lot of
the intermediate calculations
you reuse in doing the
estimate of variance.
And you still want
to ask the question,
do I have evidence that
the wafer-to-wafer variance
is bigger than the
within wafer variance?
Is there group-to-group
deviation going on?
So the ANOVA table is still
valid for asking that question.
And that's what he does here.
He's got total deviations
from the grand mean.
Remember he had 6 wafers,
3 measurements each,
18 total measurements.
So the sum of
squares divided by 17
is an estimate of
observed total variation.
And then he calculates the
wafer-to-wafer sum of squares.
He has the residual, because
he's got three replicates
at each case.
He can form the f over that
and look at the statistics
associated with that.
And that ratio, 20 times
as much mean square
from wafer-to-wafer compared to
within wafer, basically saying,
that's very significant.
There is definitely a
wafer-to-wafer effect.
That's not just the
same as sampling
coming from within wafer.
Highly significant.
So this is standard ANOVA.
And then he very nicely plops
out the variance decomposition.
The variance components.
And notice what he's done here.
Part of it is based on
directly the observed results
coming directly from the ANOVA.
In fact, if I were to take
the total sum of squares,
divide it by its
degree of freedoms,
that is my mean square.
And that's my sigma
squared t observed.
My wafer mean square,
that's sigma squared w bar.
The observed
wafer-to-wafer variance,
which was the sum
of squares divided
by its degree of freedom.
And then this is my sigma
squared measurement.
That's my random estimates.
Notice again, these do not sum.
[LAUGHS] This is the
naive calculations.
You do not want to use those
for your variance component
estimates.
In order to get
to that, you start
with number one, random
variation, the replicate error.
That's a good estimate.
But then you unwrap to
get your best estimate
of sigma squared wafer-to-wafer,
by subtracting off and then
counting for the
sampling effects.
And then you sum those together
to get sigma t squared.
And what this has done
out here in the percent
is simply now assigned a
percentage of wafer-to-wafer
versus within wafer variance.
And so in this case, about
87% of the observed variance
is because of wafer-to-wafer.
And only about 13% is
within wafer variance.
Now, how did he actually
go and do this calculation?
Well, it's those
formulas that I gave you.
Or he says, run SAC
PROC NESTED in SAS.
That's all he gives you.
OK?
So what I tried to do
is in that spreadsheet
that I posted on the
website, is actually
go in and do the
calculations that you
need in order to get to
those variance components,
for this example.
And it's basically just applying
all these formulas and concepts
that we've already
been talking about.
The tricky piece is actually
appropriately counting
for sampling effects.
How many samples go
into the denominator
to subtract off the sampling
effect, the sigma squared
over m?
It's pretty easy in
the two-level case.
But now when I have measurements
within wafers within lots,
I've got two levels
of sampling going on.
And I got to know
what factors to use.
It's not just sigma
squared over m.
We'll see in a moment,
it's sigma squared
of something divided by m
times the number of wafers.
And my spreadsheets try to help
keep careful track of that.
In the one-level case,
it's pretty easy.
Let me get to two
levels in just a second.
But the other thing that
essentially Drain's book
just pulls out of the air is the
interval estimates, again based
on SAC PROC NESTED.
And there's no help at all
in terms of where you come up
with interval estimates.
So basically, my
best recommendation
is simply use our concept
of chi-squared distributions
with the appropriate estimate
of the number of degrees
of freedom or the
number of data points
going into the estimate
of that variance piece.
And my spreadsheet also
shows some of that for you.
By the way, if you
actually do that,
it turns out that
the book claims
for the total variance and the
wafer variance and the error
variances, that those are
95% confidence intervals.
But I think those are actually
90% confidence intervals
if you do the calculation
with the chi-squared formula
down here.
So I'm actually not sure exactly
what's going into his tables.
I get slightly
different answers.
But I think the best
conservative estimate,
which may have a slight
amount of extra overcounting
of variance, but it's a slightly
larger confidence interval.
That is to say
it's conservative,
you're not fooling yourself,
and thinking things
are significant
when they're not,
is simply use the
chi-squared distribution.
And so that's what my
best recommendation
for the interval estimates are.
OK, so we're pretty
comfortable with two levels?
Let's do three levels.
Great fun.
It's the same idea.
But now I have, not only
measurements within wafers.
I have wafers within lots.
So I may have a random
lot-to-lot effect.
So I pull 24 wafers, I
do lots of processing.
I pull another 24 wafers,
I do some processing.
There is a lot average that may
be different from another lot
average, from different
from another lot
average, because there's a
lot-to-lot variance at work,
in addition now.
OK?
So this is two
levels of nesting,
or a three-level
variance structure.
Now what happens with the
observed lot-to-lot variance?
It's the same idea.
But now we've got multiple
levels of sampling going on.
You may not be able to see
it, but over that l right
here, there is a bar.
Again, this is
sigma squared l bar.
The observed
lot-to-lot variation.
And what it's got in it is
the true lot-to-lot variance.
But it's also got wafer-to-wafer
variance noise added onto it.
And then on top
of that, it's also
got replication within wafer
variance noise added onto it.
Now, the good thing is,
I've got multiple wafers.
Say I've got 24
wafers in each lot.
So the effect of the 24
wafer-to-wafer variance noise
gets reduced by my factor
of w of equal to 24.
And similarly, also, within
each of those wafers,
I may have 10 measurements.
And that noise is
multiplicatively averaged out.
I've got a factor of the number
of measurements, say it's 10,
and number of wafers
in a lot, would say
it was 24 wafers in each lot.
That's an awful lot of
data of measurement noise
that has lots of chances
with a big denominator
here to average out.
So that factor starts to
get smaller fairly rapidly.
The lowest levels start
to become smaller.
But the basic strategy
is going to be the same.
A phrase I've heard, or
maybe Drain uses, is,
what we want to do is estimate
the individual variance
components, three
levels, but think of it
as peeling the onion
from the inside out.
I'm confident at the innermost
level of the variance
of measurements.
Once I have that, I have
the observed wafer-to-wafer
variance, and I could
subtract the sampling out.
So now I have the
next inner level
of the onion, a good
estimate for that.
Using that, I can
subtract out that sampling
from the outermost level
of observed variances.
So it's the same strategy,
we work from the inside
out to get estimates of the
outer levels of variance.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This one
gives a different answer
if you do two wafers
and three measurements
or three wafers and
two measurements.
DUANE BONING: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: It's saying
there's a better
way of doing things,
like [INAUDIBLE] wafer
with fewer measurements.
DUANE BONING: Absolutely.
So what Nalish is
saying here is,
you can imagine you will
get different answers if I
had two measurements on each of
3 wafers, 6 total measurements,
for example.
Or if I took those
same 6 measurements
and I did 3 measurements
on only 2 wafers.
Those denominators
are different.
And your precision of your
estimates will be different.
Both your point estimates
may be slightly different.
But also your
confidence intervals
will be different, because in
essence, the amount of noise
is going differently
in the two cases,
and the number of
samples is going.
So that's jumping ahead
about two more slides,
but it's exactly
the point that this
does have an important
implication on sampling.
How you construct
your sampling plan,
how you allocate your
total measurement budget
and total replication
budget, depending
on which variance maybe you want
to estimate most accurately.
Let me just
qualitatively show you
the results here for the
three-level example in Drain.
This is building on
the two-level example,
so we're still looking
at sheet resistance.
We now have 3 wafers
within each lot.
So this is lot 1, lot 2,
all the way up to 11 lots.
And then within each lot,
the two little triangles
here, we're taking two
measurements within each wafer.
Now qualitatively, what do you
think is the biggest source
of invariance in this data?
Is it within wafer,
wafer-to-wafer, or lot-to-lot?
AUDIENCE: Wafer-to-wafer.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So I hear a vote, and I
kind of concur with it,
wafer-to-wafer looks pretty big.
So for example,
here's wafer-to-wafer,
another wafer-to-wafer.
Within wafer, it's
pretty nicely clustered.
So I don't expect a big
within-wafer variance.
Lot-to-lot's a
little harder to see,
because I have to
average these 3 wafers.
But it looks like there is
some lot-to-lot variations.
But it looks a
little bit smaller.
So it looks to me like sigma
squared wafer is bigger
than sigma squared
lot, which is bigger
than sigma squared measurement.
So let's see if that comes out
of our variance components.
I've given you also
this giant spreadsheet
table with all of that data.
And again, the estimates.
There's again, the
standard ANOVA, and then
the splitting out into
the variance components.
In the standard ANOVA, you
can actually ask the question,
is there statistical evidence
for wafer-to-wafer variation?
So it's basically, that
ratio right there is 62.
And it's highly unlikely
that that's by chance alone.
He also does, is there evidence
for lot-to-lot variance?
And in the standard ANOVA,
it looks pretty weak.
Given the amount of
wafer-to-wafer variance,
the ANOVA table is
saying, what you
may be observing for your
lot-to-lot deviations,
is because there's big
wafer-to-wafer variation.
It may not be a significant
lot-to-lot variance.
So that's interesting.
Let's come back to
that in a second.
Oops.
Now we can go in, this is
just the ANOVA mean squares.
But then you do this
unwrapping of the variance,
accounting for sampling.
And what he observes is, the
pure replication variance
is pretty small.
The wafer invariance
is pretty large.
There's a small remaining
lot-to-lot point
estimate of variance.
And then we have
our total variance.
So if I decompose that,
it looks like about 89%
is wafer-to-wafer, 3% is within
wafer, very small within wafer.
And here at this
point estimate is
8% of the variance,
that's my best guess.
8% of the variance
is coming from
separate lot-to-lot variance.
That's point estimates.
There's something
nagging me here
about this ANOVA observation.
That lot-to-lot variance
wasn't significant.
What if we looked at the
confidence intervals?
This now looks at the
interval estimates.
And what we see here is,
here's our point estimate
for the replication.
And it's got a range
from 1 to about 3.
Not too bad of a range for that.
My wafer variance, I had
about 56 as my point estimate.
And that, based on the numbers
of samples and everything
that I've got, might
range from 33 to 113.
And here's the
interesting thing.
If we do that point estimate
for our lot variance,
but actually look at the
chi-squared or it's again,
this weird, slightly something
different than chi-squared
but very close to it.
What you get in this case is a
negative estimate for the lower
limit of lot variance.
Woohoo.
When a confidence interval
intersects 0, that tells you
it might be 0.
So in fact, we would set
the lower bound to 0.
If I still needed my
best point estimate,
I would still stick with the 5.
But this is basically telling
me, consistent with the ANOVA,
that I don't have more than
95% confidence that there's
a non-zero lot-to-lot
variance at work.
And in fact, if I wanted
to, I might go back
and say, I'm going to set
and assume in a new model
that the lot-to-lot
variance is 0.
And I'm going to attribute
that, lump that together
with the wafer-to-wafer,
and build
just a two-level
nested invariance
where I don't include that as
a separate variance source.
Since it wasn't
significant, you might not
want to include
that in your model.
Is there a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So for this analysis,
what's the degree
of freedom that you're going
to use in the chi-square?
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
It's a little bit tricky,
but it's in the spreadsheet.
Basically, what you do is if
you look at the denominator
when you take the
sampling effect,
so it might be m times
w, or m times w minus 1,
because I have a grand mean.
When I'm doing that for
the lot-to-lot variance,
that would be my
degree of freedom.
So the degree of
freedom that you use,
the n minus 1 in
the chi-squared,
changes depending on which
variance you're estimating,
which variance interval.
And I actually have
both the definitions
with the variable names
in the spreadsheet,
and then what the numbers
are for this data.
So that is tricky.
But it basically, is anytime
you're estimating a variance,
you have a sum of
squared deviations.
And then you take
the mean square.
What's going down
in the denominator
in the mean square
estimate, that's
what you're using for
the degree of freedom.
AUDIENCE: Are they still
the same as ANOVA analysis?
DUANE BONING: Not quite.
Where they're really based
is based on these things.
So you'll see that
in the spreadsheet.
So the last point
I wanted to make
has to do with, we've already
talked about this a little bit,
how you allocate the
measurement budget.
And the simple observation is,
when you're out in outer level,
if I'm trying to estimate
the lot-to-lot variance,
what most strongly affects that?
And it's basically the data
in the outermost level,
because the variance component
of the innermost level
gets averaged away
fairly quickly.
So the contamination
of measurement variance
can be reduced if you pick
your sampling plan easily.
By the way, you
might still actually
care about sigma squared in the
observed mean-to-mean averages.
We said that it's not the best
estimate of the true, say,
wafer-to-wafer average.
But if I were doing SPC,
statistical process control
charting, based on, I
observed some sampling plan
and I observe and I plot on
my chart, an observed wafer
average, that may be what
I want to control on.
And so I actually
might still want
to use that, the sigma x bar,
for setting of my control
limits, because that's the
data that I'm charting.
So don't throw away our
old idea of keeping track
of the observed wafer average.
Just recognize
that it's actually
got a mix of a couple of
variance components inside
of it.
OK, and then the last point
here was simply the point
that Nalish already made,
is, if you're really
looking for an outer level
variance estimate, what
you want to do is push more
data to the lower levels,
in order to reduce these things.
So for example, if I allocated
almost all of my data
just to m, that reduces
this factor a lot,
but not this factor very much.
So to get the biggest
multiplicative
bang for the buck,
what you want to do
is push it just barely
outside of the factor
that you're trying to estimate.
So if I'm looking at
lot-to-lot variance,
I need at least multiple w's to
get rid of the wafer-to-wafer
effect.
And then I get the
multiplicative effect
also with the m.
That already is multiplying
up fairly rapidly.
But if I want to
suppress this factor,
I need at least some
number of wafer replicates.
On the other hand, if I think
that variance is very small,
and this variance
is very large, I
might allocate more
to the m factor.
So this can influence
your strategy
for how you pick your
sampling plans when
you've got nested structures.
OK, so to summarize, we
have been looking here
at nested variance structures
with this weird grouping
within one group within another
group within another group.
First off, you should be
able to recognize when you've
got nested variance structures.
Second, hopefully now
you've got at least a feel
for how you would estimate those
separate variance components.
And then there is a little bit
of implications on design plans
that hopefully you're alert to.
So you will have a chance to
play around with this at least
a little bit on the
problem set, if you
haven't started that already.
Do look at the spreadsheet.
I think that will be a
big help to you on that.
So with that, we'll end.
And I'll stick
around for a minute,
because it sounds like there's
a question in the Singapore end.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
just have a question.
Should I ask now?
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
But you guys should feel
free to go if you want here.
AUDIENCE: How do you tell
whether it's a fixed effect
or if it's a nested variance?
DUANE BONING: Oh, good question.
How do you tell if it's a fixed
effect or nested variance?
That's a model assumption.
So I think the basic idea
is, if it's a fixed effect,
and I think I'm changing
my group-to-group by, say,
a design, if wafer
number 2 in the lot
always has a delta of
some size as opposed
to being randomly
sampled, that might
be a systematic fixed effect.
But just raw data, I don't know.
You actually have to look at
the setup of the situation
to know whether each one is
treated as a wafer replicate,
or if I'm doing something
different to each wafer
intentionally.
That would be a fixed effect.
OK?
All right?
So Thursday, we'll
see you on Thursday
with Dan Frey as
a guest lecturer.